okay four people joining this livestream
we are reviewing some new visualization
features for the upcoming version of
language and somebody is making much
background noise there and should just
it was probably me shifting my chairs
okay alright where are we starting here
did we do we need to come back to any of
these multiple plot things or are we oh
we did we did we conclude something did
we conclude did you fix those things
about where the weather labels go
sorry ours muted um so the notebook I
just sent you has an updated visual for
that and I think it can even go a little
bit further I just haven't had it it
occurred to me middle of the day today
I'm having a chance to play with it yet
so that's the updated text position
under multi-panel graphics grid okay
and the mags are still gonna be kind of
wonky but so that's gonna be one key oh
the thickness of the frames there okay
Oh under magnification because I haven't
oh under Magnum magnified view okay
right so so this is the idea that you
had last time this one here right where
we you know sort of only drop things
where they're getting close to other
things
positionally nuts yeah this isn't
horrible the truth is we could go well I
mean so so there's two things I think
fits we can do one of them easy and one
a little bit more complicated I mean
these gutters are big enough that
everything would fit on pay for those
numbers maybe but you'd have fifty and
zero getting really close together okay
but so anyway my two thoughts are you
know for the first column in the last
column right I mean we could still do
the full ticks there and only have the
truly interior ones dropped the end
points so the first time you're saying
the first column I see the first and
last columns could be complete that's a
good idea
right a good idea so so that's the easy
one the more the other one which i think
is possible but i need to figure out how
to do it is to still have the ticks when
we drop them I think that would be
really good I fully support that I think
having first and last before is good I
think having all ticks is really a very
nice thing and then the middle one is
what we had before
and then the last one is just throwing
ticks on everything so is there an
option to do that yes
grid your method grid ticks right well I
think we should be able to tune this so
that it's really good for everybody
in the end brent so i don't think we can
leave it as a method option for the time
being you're saying leave it as a method
option or yeah I'm saying yeah option
things don't we don't want to promote it
to some fancier option no I don't think
so not right now at least hopefully we
can tweak it so that nobody will ever
need to set that option right okay okay
all right
here should we look at this yeah sure so
the default setting for alignment for
the graphics grid graphics row graphics
column family is Center Center and I
mean there's probably cases where I mean
I'm concerned that if I sort of turn on
my stuff everywhere that you know
there's gonna be lots of cases that you
know somebody was relying on yes how can
you turn it on so what are you proposing
here I'm proposing that we turn it on
via alignment goes to some setting
either all or full or which as far as I
can tell on the docks isn't actually
used right now sorry what where are you
trying to set this so I would set it
inside graphics no graphics grid
graphics row that sort of thing
sorry for the
says okay you only implicitly use a
graphics row or a graphics collar you
know graphics grid right what do you
mean by implicitly well this doesn't say
graphics grid anywhere right and that's
actually not going through graphics grid
okay so what are we talking about
graphics grid here I mean because
there's no two aspects to this project
one is the multi column stuff coming out
of these functions yes and the other is
trying to improve graphics grid okay but
so this is not a good example I mean
you're saying so suggests you know right
now Stephen it's a it's a it's a minor
but useful update to graphics grid that
can have to get the axes to line up yes
yeah well that's good so why don't we
say alignment are automatic because I
think automatic means something let's
find out it's probably just gonna point
you to alignment yeah well that's
clearly not gonna work just leave it a
center Center
well the fault
based alignment based on environment
sounds okay to me okay yeah I think so
I mean we've also got
string alignment don't we yes well but
that's a lining on a character no no I
understand that okay fine I think I
think automatic should be fine
okay okay
and are we making that to the folder
we're making people opt-in I think I
should make it the default
I think otherwise nobody will be able to
deal with this I it should just work
show confidence in your code and eat the
bug reports you know sounds good
I'll still have you know some hidden ah
you know global variable to revert back
to the old code if any because like no
graphic in that crap um you know Wolfram
Alpha or somebody is slow to update
occasionally so yes and so then
other thing is I think we really need to
change frame and axis to automatic for a
bunch of functions agreed not like
though that if axes switches off if you
have a frame is that the idea unless
it's some sister so the reason that I
want to change I mean so the core reason
I want to change frame and axes is for
the case above you know that list line
plot is framed not exceed mm-hm
I could have axes I mean it could but I
don't think that's what you want is the
default in a column approach no and so I
need the automatic for that at least
yes and since they're automatic then I
think it would be really nice to have
frame and axes toggle and sync by
default you know so if you say free
accepted except for the case where the
axes where the thing I mean there are
cases where you want to see the origin
even though you have a frame but yes
that should be a case you have to set
explicitly that might break some stuff
for people what does it do right now in
a plot if you say frame so right now it
leaves the axes but if the axis is
within ten percent of the IC then it
dumps it then it dumps it behavior right
but I mean shouldn't that be the
automatic behavior so for plots maybe
that's the automatic behavior unless
it's in a column in which case it dumps
the axes altogether I mean if I think
experience has been that every time I've
you know set frame goes to true there's
a 95% chance that I'm then setting axis
goes to false agreed I think it's more
like eighty percent for me but yes I
agree there's a high probability and and
you know setting them to automatic
doesn't prevent you from setting both of
them to true no I understand that
I I'm look I'm just concerned about
breaking stuff where people have assumed
that axes will continue to be on even
when they put a frame there it's it's
not it's a no-brainer to say if you're
going to do the multi panel thing then
you can get rid of axes I have no
problem with that right I'm just
considering the case where I think it's
a little bit more of an issue and we
should look at documentation other
examples to decide that when you know
that we should do this I don't have a
problem in having access to automatic by
default okay but the question is what
the behavior should be and whether it
should always switch them off as soon as
there's a frame it should that it's okay
I think access to automatic should
switch off should switch I cheese off
when there is a frame by default mmm
I think that's okay can we think that
through could you send out mail to
people and just think that through with
all the functions because you're you
know you're listing you know
statistically a bunch of functions here
and I have no idea like like this one
here that has true/false what is that
one I believe that's audio plot okay so
so it has a frame in an x-axis okay so
this one here for example what's that I
think those are a couple of the
financial plots and I don't know why
they're true true and not just true okay
well I mean you've got to go through
this in more detail but I guess I'm okay
with your main conclusion okay Nelson
and out an email to proxies to automatic
do right now here what does that one do
I don't remember which that is I think
you need to look at the ones that say
axes to true mean because you've got
plenty with your axes to false so let's
find out which functions have ax is true
do I should I do this how do I do that
let me can you send me the list see if I
still have that nipperkin I mean it's
interesting this one would actually true
and frame to true it's no X is true
frame automatic is parametric plot
because the frame turns on when you have
a region yeah well that's a nice case I
think that code got lost in the front
end trash I can regenerate it okay fine
then send it through yep okay let's go
back are we looking at your your
notebook here are we going back to
Rogers I would look at my notebook I
think mine has all the interesting cases
for the remaining functions okay complex
plot so this is you know so there's four
complex plotting functions now REM plot
ABS art plots complex plot and complex
plot 3d and and so we have this option
for complex plot and I think complex
plot 3d although it's less interesting
they're less necessary there on how the
ABS component gets represented and right
now with the default behavior is that
the ABS component isn't represented at
all within complex plots all you see is
the art coloring why aren't you
representing it with gray level as
the second case because it's tricky
actually so Stephen the third case is
just pure it's not gray level it's it's
no saturation brightness yeah and and so
we have like three four and five I think
are all different approaches on this I
don't think we should claim one of them
we needed a name to set it to well let's
give it a name that represents something
to do with its functionality because
nobody's ever gonna know what any of
these are right so taller is a global
scale
it is dark at zero and light at infinity
and so depending on what you're you know
if so that's like -2 to 2 in each
direction if you did minus 10 to 10 then
the light and dark areas would get
smaller the one that is Wolfram is
[Music]
darkened for the bottom 5% of height
values and lightened for the top 5% in
quantile plot top five percent quantile
wise quantile wise yes so we have a
sampling of our ABS over a grid on the
domain and the top 5% bottom five
percents get lightened and darkened do
we have somebody from graphic design
here no could we ask okay
shading we've not had that option before
is that correct no and possibly we want
something that is more I mean if we
wanted to play it safe it could be
complex shading or something or you know
that's tighter to this set of functions
well this is shading related to the ABS
is that right or its trading relates to
both the ABS and the argh
it's shading relating to ABS and the
reason that it's not just rolled into
color function is that then we can
change the color function for the Arg
independently sort of more recently why
doesn't color function with a with that
two arguments being fed into it
I mean colorful Ken but but it's it's
very use it's very hopeless to use
Steven that's the problem okay super for
for instance density plot 3d opacity we
have an opacity function right so it's
it could be rolled into a color function
but it's hopeless to use because you
want to change the hue scale
independently of opacity
okay it can be done it's just not using
the wrong name this has to do with the
you know this is I mean it would be
something like ABS color function you
could do that if you wanted I mean in
which case I would just go with complex
shading well that maybe sounds a bit
weird but you can call it ABS or guiding
true that would work because that will
allow you to then give a function which
can take the ABS and the org as
arguments right I mean so I think it
actually does take a function and it
actually takes you know all four
components REM ABS argh
I mean color function does also but I
think color function shading does as
well well internally yes we we didn't
expose that and and it does apply on the
art as well
so so if you scroll down a little bit
more you get the really crazy ones that
you know are shading by argh or ABS and
argh
what is this showing here so the left
part is the ABS shading or a
representation of the ABS shading and so
a lot of these are basically cyclic in
log ABS so that you get enough you know
so that you get periods that show you
behavior and you can sort of see
relative rates of growth so to speak and
and these are all images that I've set
the magnification to 50% so you can make
them bigger if you want or need to why
is it looking
batchi here it's a bitmap yes like I
said they're images that have been can I
just run this sure okay so that's a
logarithmic scale in the ABS and in the
org are you always relating it with pies
I mean that will make it fairly clear
that it's the argh
I think we're always labeling it with
pies that with degrees mendes bar lurch
and take a target units option it's
probably not doing what you're thinking
it's doing it's just adding the unit
okay so it's not converting so we should
have a way of doing that in degrees
agreed okay so the issue here is both
the name and the default I'm not a big
fan of having the default not to have
any encoding of abs and you know if we
have one that we thought we would
proudly call after ourselves why the
heck don't we use that as the default
right so so that would become automatic
and the top one would become none okay
but then that's actually not that would
be an abs or we
ABB's and the current abs we can make
cyclic abs or something well I'm not
sure what they okay so the issue here is
you are using so so color function if
I'm understanding correctly applies only
to the Arak
is that correct I mean color function by
default applies only to the argh so the
hash one of the color function is the
ABS as the our Grover slot one is Reece
lot 2 is M slot 3 is ABS ABS and slot 4
is argh well then maybe we should call
this ABS our color function which is
just a Reece lotting of the color
function care what I'm saying if you
really think it's important to have
these orthogonal options that were the
obvious way to do it it's the same as a
color function but with color functions
the thing gets to apply itself to re em
you know AB Zog right and in this case
it gets to apply itself probably to ABS
org making sense I mean I personally
don't think this is right because I
think that this again Roger can you say
what your issue was I mean that so the
the main thing ok so I think we getting
we're muddling a few things up together
here so Steven can you try something
real quick ok take whichever one of
those you like the most or choose one at
random let's choose this one ok and
change the color function to rainbow say
string rainbow what
start applying the color function to
that's gonna fly to argh why is it
applying dog you just told me that it
applied to have four arguments yes and
strings are special and we get to choose
what they apply to okay then I think
probably the color function has the
arguments fed in the wrong order now
look why don't you have the color
function why don't you have color
function feed initially to argh then it
would just work in plug 3d does the same
thing color function arguments are X Y Z
Z is the default or our names
oh yeah but but still the fact that we
go r.e.m ABS argh
well I guess okay yeah all right okay so
what's your point here so so so the
point is that what you just did Steven
was to change the hue it's a 1d color
function and you just changed at I
understand this is quite nice and I
think if the first thing was called all
muddled up you would have I know I know
I know that's why I'm suggesting call
that other one AB Zog color function
right and then the second the pure color
function a string will by default apply
to the Arg or it will apply to all four
of those things and the ABS odd color
function you could also have be a string
be something or other there that applies
itself to the ABS by default the one
argument form applies to the ABS right I
mean so so what that I mean what your
abs are color function needs is one of
its arguments though is the color from
color function oh really
I mean so going back to the one I'm
sorry how does that work what does it do
then it's gonna build a new color right
so it's gonna combine two colors how
would some kind of blend or what yes
something like that you know or converts
it to you know lab or something and does
lightness and dark assumes you know in
my prototype at least you know which we
didn't have this but then you would
strip all the other components of the
color and you would keep the hue and
then apps are is in charge of the outer
components which is saturation and value
you know Sandro livestream is making the
point that if we have it given that we
have an opacity function which after all
also does this kind of you know this is
a retrofit our light opacity function
goes on top of the existing color
function is that correct mm-hmm yes so
then the obvious thing to do will be to
have some kind of shading function that
goes on top of the color function also
that's a shading function might be a bit
general yeah but what should we call it
then but the problem with shading is
that there's my name morphing is coming
for shading fine right I would be fine
with complex shading function I mean
especially
or you know especially since it's going
to be a very specific to ABS argh sorts
of things
Roger what do you think about that given
all the other things that are coming
with shading I'm a little bit leery
about using shading it's I mean I think
it should be called color again cuz we
are using color again I hope you already
call it ABS ABS color function complex
color function are you sure we can't do
this with some kind of right-hand side
to color function why can't we just do
this why can't we just say color
function in the cases that you want it
why can't we just say you know thala
comma rainbow they can work okay
a corner case let's not invent some huge
mechanism to do this if this is what you
want you wanted you know call it by numb
by name so to speak let's have names for
the color function that are um you know
we can even prefix these names by some
complex or something to indicate I don't
think they need to be prefixed and we
can do that I am taller rainbow a
rainbow taller well I don't think it
should matter well in the case that you
give of pure functions for both it will
I see then it should be a hog well
you're suggesting it's our gabs the Arg
function in the ABS function okay but
what happens
specify if you want the default AAG
automatic but okay I mean I mean that
said we could accept you know color
function goes to taller on its own I
would think so I mean that's not a
problem I mean we can disambiguate
strings all over the place yeah all
right okay I think this is what we
should do
the only question is this is all gaps or
ABS argh I think Argost and most
important probably and but nevertheless
in this case by the time you've got the
double string I think it should be abs
are in to correspond to this if you're
actually gonna specify both of them and
anyway if you specify a single string
it'll just go to the argh by default I
see a cured yeah okay
now what are we going to name these
things these are varying consistently
named yeah we shouldn't keep these names
so just tell me what these are
okay so the first one is none second one
is why is that none oh because it
actually has nothing there it's not
coloring right yeah okay and the second
one is AB cycles sounds like some kind
of weird exercise um
absolute steal um I'll put that as an
alias for you Roger okay why is it why
is it ABS cycles why is it why is that
the right name because the shading is I
mean the effect of the shading is cyclic
you know ABS isn't cyclic of course but
yeah well I think ABS cyclic would be
better than ABS cycles oh we could use a
mod type term
no I think cyclic is better I don't
think cyclic abs I like better than AB
cyclic it really I don't know it's just
somehow he's here to say but it isn't
sick like I mean what do you think the
the the words that describe this thing
are they I actually come to us yes
that's true well they're not they're not
really contours their abs they're
approximation to contours what do you
mean well I mean so a contour is you
know a single curve we could have
contours that's a perfectly interesting
thing to have right and we can do that
with mesh that's right not controversial
right I mean but so you know every one
of those egg shapes right corresponds to
a constant ABS value right sure yes I
mean you get to see the contours just
visually because that's the place where
there's a big jump in the opacity level
by the way no this is no no no no it's
not a pasty it's it's saturation and
value it's in the HSV color model okay
but so if we what would be the third
thing to say here if we said ABS cyclic
and then we said brightness or something
the value or value is confusing well we
need to add HSV color moral but that
make any sense I don't know I think this
is a case
we're having something that's entirely
accurate doesn't help right yes you know
we could name them Bob and Tom and
whatever turnaround live stream is
asking about color function scaling
which was also something I was wondering
about for the minus PI to PI business
and so on how do you determine what that
range is that you're going to feed to
the color function I think you're going
to need some string names for color
function scaling to determine whether
it's minus PI to PI or 0 to PI so if you
say color function scaling goes to false
then you will get minus PI to PI ok true
is 0 to 1 ok how about 0 to PI scaling
do 4 so can you independently set the
color function scaling for abs and AAG
yes ok
okay what is the Falla thing so Feller
is a global gradient of light to dark
you see I'm saying that there's no
banding in this case Steven
yeah I see that but I'm just trying to
understand do we really want to name it
after somebody so nobody knows what it
is do you wanna call it I mean I'm fine
calling it something else yeah I don't
really like tombstone names even for
functions they don't tell you anything
about it unless you have the secret joke
list
I mean it's just that so that one is
sort of an absolute absurd of thing
right so AB squared Y squared is
absolute ABS what's this one man that is
what this mean so that's the quantile
one and so that will be automatic name
anyway yeah sure one downside to that
thaller one is that it tends to be
either very white or very dark I'm
saying well I mean it depends on what
how big your scale is it does but but
having looked at many of those plots
they tend to be either very white very
dark as a general rule well then that's
a bad choice I mean then we should fix
the heuristic yeah no I'm just saying
that that's that's what it does and the
fixed heuristic is the quantile one did
you so below there you mean the fallow
thing is you're saying it's bad because
it is yeah there's cases where it looks
good but you know all right so quantile
ABS which is otherwise known as
automatic okay do we have more names
what is bang only situation because so
the scene that is that how do we
represent that in the legend it is
difficult to have ball saturation and
brightness to be represented in the
legend for the con what the heck is that
well that's certainly not not a winner
those can be cleaned up right that's
that's that's a different problem yes
also be zero infinity okay what this is
and how it relates to this other one up
here well so the quarter one is that if
it is a pole then you are the just the
brightness so that in dark if it is a
zero then you're the judge the situation
so we can light but these mmm mechanism
is very difficult to represent in the
legend on the light left-hand side of
the legend
and then so we saw that you know so that
the idea of only showed a situation is
very similar to opacity function
you only have one parameter there I mean
to me this one looks better than this
one I mean this one it really draws
attention to the you know the weird
black and white spots which are quite
meaningless mm-hm
I mean this seems like a much better
representation I mean we could make that
the default I would think that should be
the default and how does it look at
different scales the implementation in
the build currently is an absolute but
we were thinking about maybe we should
experiment with the concave as well I
mean the absolute probably works okay in
this case right
it looks very beautiful I don't know
what it is but it looks beautiful anyway
so the zero is the light spots the zeros
the colorful points now you see Oh see
just have to look at the legend of right
right right yes if we make ping the
default I mean it's very very I think
this is more scientifically scientific
looking this looks more like some kind
of weird you know planet scape on a on a
triple star or something which
eliminated by multiple lights there are
others
that's even more crazy you have to
arranged for it to be interesting even
then it's still not that interesting
yeah oops that looks less misleading
than this is that you also gonna fix the
scale right right but it there can just
be zero to infinity okay but what's the
auto scaling of the of the grayness
levels how does that work it's absolute
right men for yours that's never gonna
work absolute is never gonna work
hey what do you mean by absolute
absolute within the the plot range or
absolute absolute what's in the it's
actually within the four inch yes so
it's not really zero to infinity okay
but I think we can effectively label it
a zero to infinity what well I mean is
it just kind of tunt is just gonna be
white what's it kind of look like is it
logarithmic is it not logarithmic it is
and by the way when you dis logarithmic
we should be saying that in these things
here I agree
global log abs or something okay all
right so listen my strong thing is don't
have these black holes all over the
place okay sounds good please I mean I
think that's a mistake I think it makes
them look silly um okay so can you can
iterating on these things that I think I
think we've got the default clear
he's a nice to me this is very nice okay
so is it the case that there are there
also hires that are interesting things
that you can read off from this Steven
so for instance you can read off the
zero to order of a zero or the order of
a pole I understand by saying how many
times it goes around right and that
means that you can also see when there
is an essential singularity for instance
yes I think this is very cool very cool
so let's let's just look for one ok so
there's also a complex plot 3d is that
correct yes so that uses geometry for
ABS obviously yes so the you know
shading will be none for it by default I
see I see I see I see so so that um so
we have a plot range arrow scaled
something rather we don't have that do
we no that's quite magnificent really
let's just do something famous here why
is it taking so long it's evaluation
time for Zeta I know well there's the
big pole hum
a line I mean if you sometimes you if
you want plot 1 over Zeta instead might
be more interesting and kick up the way
range the in range yeah well doesn't
matter I'm just playing here ok well
it's quite beautiful is that the usual
default for the for cutting it off I
thought it was gray usually when you cut
it off it normally when you see it cut
off it's under you know the regular the
default lights and then this is neutral
it has to be neutral Stephen obviously
yeah but but wise it looks white
shouldn't it be gray no White's the
usual it's just under the lights that we
project onto it with a usual setup
it looks gray or whatever right ok well
this looks wonderful and anything
further to figure out what this I don't
think so I think the color yeah
whichever name it was we ended up with
is well this color function trading is
irrelevant in this case right this is
purely color function yes right I mean
it probably you know is you know this
with this form that the the 0 is around
the Reds what is this thing anyway is
the soap rainbow spectrum or what this
is a brand new color function okay so
this is color data of balance to you
that's a good idea
so it's very close to hue but it doesn't
get quite as bright in the yellows or
the science but a brightness hasn't
perceived human brightness which is that
right
correct good it's nice are we gonna use
that elsewhere as well probably maybe
and okay this is the first example of us
doing a two-dimensional color function
if you scroll up when we add dabs yes
yeah I get it okay all right so then
there's a couple other options for the
complex plots you know somebody's asking
an interesting question on a live stream
can you export a slowly rotating video
or gift for presentations
the answer is it's easy to write code to
do that but it would be actually an
interesting thing to be able to do that
automatically and we had a plan for that
right Rodrigue years ago yes and
actually we will revitalize that now
because we working on video and
naturally give export has been updated
we could do that there too but I think
we'll have a lot of things that's gonna
make it easier to produce videos
including those slowly rotating things
which is obviously a very good idea
which yes we added every method - what's
that and yeah we meant - and a whole
slew of other things which will now
reactivate good ok let's go on to the
next thing
okay so the reom plot has a couple of
options I just created wise reemployed
what it is it has a rough age but so
there's a thing that I can do instead of
complex plot you're saying here right
yeah so there's re-employed and abs
aargh plot which are plotting over a
real variable instead of a complex
variable well that's rather
unpleasant yeah
yeah well take care of that so do you
need Z's it real now what is this - so
this pause anticipatory think of you you
requested this Stephen first of all but
second it's when you have a real
argument like a Fourier transform the
frequency is real yes okay so if you
have just it means that you have
basically two curves of a single
parameter so so to REM plot of square
root of x x goes from minus 5 to 5 oh oh
oh oh oh yeah ok this is a completely
different thing yes it's completely
different thing right so that's using
dashed lines to represent the complex
case right and so it has two specialized
options
REM style which you know controls the
dashing versus you know you know what
the differentiator is 4vm style okay I
mean as opposed to having plot style go
to an association where we say you know
re her Oh blah Ameri blah correct I mean
so the other thing is that it combines
with plot styles so if you say plot
style goes to read in your REM plot then
you know still have the dashing and I
see so this is an overlay thing again
yes so if I say you know red blue word
yes sir - dotted or asked
dashed , dotted okay by the way maybe
Jeremy could would like to comment on
this I personally think dotted is a
better default than dashed for the
imaginary part oh yeah here it looks
good
I agree no but I mean so this would be 3
M style none whoops I just did that well
that's we in right right so this would
be I'm just because I know my square
root I think this is that's better than
the dashed case could you see on just a
little just set it to its default size
yeah I mean the dotting won't change I
mean the dotting will - yeah it's good
yeah that's nice my concern is that it
possibly de-emphasizes the you know that
dotted is less heavy then no don't worry
about it
this is okay it's very obvious there's
something different going on yeah I
think - does really small size it's
gonna look weird I mean so dotted does
better at small scales
okay so dotted instead of dashed yeah
but this is a useful kind of plot right
and then it's gonna dog plot so go ahead
with that and it does the same thing but
with ABS Arg and you're sort of a
complex plot sort of thing so so this is
like X plus I I mean this is you're
saying that it's a polar plot place no
no it's still one variable like
yeah so well why didn't that hoe what
what happened the first time you still
had the REM style oh I see
and so what's this represents citizens
so the height is ABS and the coloring is
you know the argh
and and in this case for square roots
you know everything is either 0 or PI or
whatever
right how do I just open the docs page
for it that's the easiest way to get
more interesting examples okay and I
think those actually need to be
reevaluated those colors are not is this
using the balanced that is using the
balanced to you again definitely the
yellow looks like it's dropping out here
these honestly look a little bit you
know the colors don't throw me here I
think it will be better given that these
are you know cuz the yellows are just
really dropping out I mean can't we use
some kind of slightly darker thing by
default I mean if you make it darker the
yellows are gonna go Brown Jeremy we
need your help I mean you could kind of
bypass yellow and merge it you'd still
go through a little bit of brown but you
could push the primary nough so these
colors does not look very good here yeah
try setting colored function goes to you
is it important to keep a continuous hue
you know something cyclic or not yes yes
okay okay that's even more garish I mean
this is a really bad color in my view I
mean so the other thing that we can do
is we can adjust the thickness
well I don't think that's gonna help but
what's the possible color data what's
about you feeling do feeling axis its
kind of do anything I don't know oh you
didn't you didn't take it down to one
function I think that was a feature that
when you had your two of those things
try feel that it's sure-sure can't okay
look that obviously looks silly
the yellow is like burning out you know
so I think we need another color
function for this something that is more
balanced can you take out the color
function can you again oh yeah that's
better
I mean the yellow is still rather you
know this is just coincidence that
yellows getting squeezed like that it's
such a small percentage no it's not a
good is it a coincidence I think it's a
property of hue okay you know green is
huge and that could be balanced better
too then I mean if you could write in
the balanced in this balancing you could
not have more yellow less green here
okay we'll see what Tim can do it really
pops out as looking like it means
something right but let's come back to
this case here where we have pure lines
that are you know hewing away so to
speak um what could we do with this I
think what would happen if we just made
it darker so in other words let's
imagine this is hue um what's HSV what
should we do
let's say I don't really know what I'm
doing here but but let's say something
like that that's obviously not very good
but but something um give me some values
here and stick a one there in the middle
right bryony's you might want it to be
uh like 75% yes I think that's better
that looks less silly than the balanced
well I don't know about balance but but
I mean that the darkness of those lines
look yeah that's basically it is
balanced exposed can you get to it color
data balanced you okay and you modify it
is there a way to yeah probably not
I mean not he's there you can't do this
right you can't do this thing darkening
I mean I could I could write a darker of
color function darker balance you
completing by the way yeah well get that
in there
hmm you need a slot yeah what did I do
wrong here I point one or something
that's not bad that's a lot better than
the original one it's a lot better I'm
I've you it's a lot better than see what
happens if we go to point two here they
seem okay Jeremy your comments yeah I
think point one was enough lease resumed
but yeah better than full brightness and
would be fill use transparency weeds
they I mean so if you have multiple
things the fills or just straight colors
if you have one of them I think it was
full opacity at the moment no I mean we
don't do that for other functions you
know we shouldn't do that here yeah if
that went down too
lassiter it would look pretty decent but
you'd have to brighten it at the same
time no it's gonna say I think we have
where are we doing that I think there's
a place where we effectively darken the
linear components of something compared
to filled regions
and I'm drawing a blank on where that is
because it was years ago that we did
that I think it's an stuff to do with
region plots isn't it isn't it isn't it
the thing where you have a parametric it
may be the region flag yeah it's where
you have a parametric we have a
parametric plot that encloses a region
versus doesn't right all right good so
we've got some minor tweaks there all
right what's next here so we I don't
think you've really looked at the genome
vector in-stream plots I have not and
also what's this interval marker
so those are I mean this were originally
errorbar something in Para bar markers
and an error bar style and the last time
we looked at those as we came up with
interval as and that's for list plot
Lisp Laden things that are you know
accepting uncertainty around if I if I
do so let me just make a table of just
just random
let's just do I think those lines are
also being affected by magnification
yeah okay fine
so now this is the style you're talking
about the style by the way what happens
if I do if I do list line plot yeah okay
beautiful and a few sets interval
markers goes to bands then you know you
won't get the discrete things but like
this mm-hmm yeah sorry it's undergoing
renaming right now so band instead of
that was fun
a little exotic what is going on there
can you send me that example yep it
should be something center
a straight line there one would think
especially since every interval yeah
it's a single it's a symmetric interval
here right that's really interesting
right why aren't these symmetric
intervals cuz generate them no he did
look I did I said around and then a
single number oh it can be negative what
is it yeah that's a bizarre case what
does it mean when the error is negative
you have no idea I mean I'm guessing
that right I mean so around isn't
actually in the system yet right
I mean Jose hasn't merged around yet
okay you better ask okay what what
around does with a negative error yep so
if you change that to you know 0.1 to
0.3 or something there we get symmetric
error yes okay so this is a pathology
that that happened for the negative from
that negative thing right so that's fine
okay and so we have a handful of named
strings at the moment and what what can
you say what what does the thing take by
default what do you mean I mean what
what does interval markers take can
gonna take name strings um it can
undocumented ly take a pure function but
I'm okay so Sandra I'll live stream is
asking um for number line plots do
interval markers work so that is a bug
at the moment I think it got reported
over the weekend er the late last week
okay but
line plot is definitely going to accept
around and that sort of thing yeah but
is it going to accept interval markers
representing both an around interval and
an interval interval really I'm saying
not entirely okay so look number line
plot has the possibility of having
actual interval specified and it's not
obvious that actual intervals should be
rendered the same way as around interval
right okay so go up to your first list
plot there okay and and you know make a
version of that that uses interval okay
maybe you want the factors of 10 back in
there okay
interval doesn't have caps on it correct
you know what they are with the
automatic markers it doesn't okay that
makes sense so interval markers does it
say does it give things which can
distinguish between intervals and around
the pure function case which isn't
documented has I think ways of getting
everything that you could possibly want
okay yeah because it also has to deal I
mean it has to deal with the case of you
know am i doing a bunch of single
functional applications like those top
two or am i doing one big functional
application like you would want with
bands right so there's some design left
to be done on that we don't need to
address that right now correct by the
way are we gonna continue for twelve one
and roll out more uncertainty plotting
and we'll we'll get to farther into this
question others for Jeremy back on here
the claim from our live stream is that
red seems to be absent but I don't think
that's correct I think we just darkened
the red here yeah no it's there zoom
issue were a live stream issue you know
the question is to use black lines
sandwiches but I don't think that will
work I think the lines are lines
um okay okay what's next here we did
uncertainty okay so we've got the Geo
vector stuff yep I think that's the last
thing okay so geo vector so we've got
the actual geo vector object okay and
and I went through this quickly with
Jose yesterday yes that's right um but
was this geo vector was this sister so
is Jose with us by the way here he is
not but he can be brought in on short
notice
let's bring him in okay Oh give him a
call real quick well
I can ask someone to do this okay um
okay
oh it was this the finger I looked at
yesterday with him as and as this now
changed to what we discussed that it
would be that was I looked at something
different yesterday no you looked at
this page yesterday and you changed
modulus to magnitude in one spot okay
fine
III got the tail end of that twitch
meeting okay okay fine
actually no I watched it the tail end of
it at home it later okay okay yeah
because we had a long discussion about
frames and so on okay so this is the
analog of geo
direction is it not but this does chil
direction have a third argument can it
go up as well I'm sure it can
how's the musical direction so that I'm
sorry that's no it's geo displacement it
doesn't seem to be able to go up so
what's the
between geo vector and geo displacement
displacement this is a difference of two
vectors I mean usually well means
displacement is relased ins on earth
it's an unanchored relative object
whereas geo vector is always anchored
it's anchored and it's not saying
anything about anywhere other than the
Anchor Point hello this is cousin hi
we're looking at real vector okay I'm
trying to understand the relationship
between geo displacement and geo vector
yes I think if you can you go to the
very last example of Geo vector plus
for example and not last last example I
think oh it's certain does not work the
previous one perhaps just yes that one
exactly so there you have the vector in
red and you have the geo displacement in
black and if you I don't know where that
works this this yeah okay so you see how
the the displacement is a geodesic and
it's curved the vector is just saying
the initial turn again by the way
there's something horribly wrong with
the arrow for the vector that is really
interesting yes the manipulate is
changing to centre well it's not
respecting they start just know that the
arrowhead is like changing in size oh
yes I fixed that thing like yesterday
okay where there's an image with image
width of the line yeah right okay so so
I'm by the way the color of these Geo
vectors did that get did that get fixed
did you get some design into that I just
asked that Jeremy for his opinion the
reason for that is that we are using
your marker and your marker by default
uses right but only uses that red does
it lose the darker red I thought that's
what I thought also if we want red it's
the red of what geo list plot the line
there which is a darker yeah spec for
that okay so um but but alright so geo
vector
schumacher of GV what is this about
yes so the idea is that in Geographics
when we have an object like at your
position we don't show a point we just
take into account for the computation of
the here range and the same thing would
happen for a G of external check in
order to draw something we have to wrap
it in a gia primitive in this case your
marker so it could be point for example
but it can point exactly
and whatever it would just be the root
of the field vector exactly okay
yes and then your marker takes in the
second argument the full specification
of vector marker so we can have any
vector marker that is supported a um
when it so we're looking then at okay so
we're looking at geo vector and that's
stream plot geo vector plot and geo
stream plot not geo vector so I would
like to get rid of those first two usage
statements location vector or you know
so don't vectors always have a base
anyway well so so the fun thing is is
that geo vector predates sorry geo
vector flat predates geo vector and and
so the original input was you know pair
of numbers pair of numbers or you know
geo position comma pair of numbers and
the vector was just you know XY or
whatever and so I I think you know it
should just eat geo vectors or you know
some flavor of geo vector all the time
well the questions
to plot have a meaningful sense without
having the UM I'm gonna have to leave
yeah I have to go soon also but but um
hold on one second um okay but those are
the locations but you're saying really
the only thing you plan to plot here
what does vector plot to take vector
plot takes you know big nested lists of
numbers so it's basically dense and
sparse no actually what what we really
want is vectors vector plot right right
right and so you have a pair of numbers
that is X what is the origin and the
pair of numbers that's the direction
okay and that's the sort of thing that I
would like to not have why I mean it
seems as a courtesy we might as well
have it I mean you can wrap it in Geo
vectors but but I don't think it should
be essential well so so part of the
issue is that especially with Geo
vectors we have a vector and geo vector
e in U so we have the polar versus the
Cartesian coordinate system at that
point
Hosea do you have any comments on this I
I'm beginning to get convinced here they
think by specifying the vector head it's
clearer which frame you are using you
know they're probably other things like
all kinds of projections and all kinds
of stuff that might go into that geo
vector right by having lists one would
have to assume more or less of it's
really one of the choices ok these
inputs are gonna get cleaned up that'll
turn into just a plain geo vector that's
right
why wind vector data I mean it seems
it's a bit like geo elevation data which
can take how does geo elevation data
take um you know it can either be at a
single point right or over a region
exactly unfortunately it seems that our
API to wind vector data cannot take
regions it has to go point by point
which is a pity because it makes it
rather slow but but surely we can I mean
that's a different that's a completely
different problem right to solve that
yes but it's an I mean I see what you
mean what is the notation we use the
other one is how do you think tannery
yes but it's going to work slower okay I
understand it but I suspect we can make
a version of wind vector data that like
geo elevation data has I mean clearly
there's a certain granularity to the way
okay whose is this is it on the
geoserver is it on some weather server
where is it this is in some external GSR
oh yes an external server of information
that we connect to it's not integers
mmm really well okay that's a separate
discussion
yeah can we bring that up with I mean is
that Francisco deals with that or
somebody else Jason Martinez okay I
think we should bring that up and if
necessary we should cash these things um
because it seems like a good thing to be
able to do and it shouldn't be very
difficult to cash it that seems like a
really big cash why it depends on the
granularity right well but it depends on
the time of course it depends on time
chill elevation doesn't change at all
real for practical purposes that's true
but it's useful to have this as a
function of time anyway and it doesn't
really matter if we accumulate a few
terabytes of data it doesn't really
matter
okay so window vector data already takes
an additional argument in which you can
say give me a vector that's very useful
okay yes that is useful I think that
landed what sometime last week so data
and your everything more than they also
do that now okay nice okay so fine so
what's the question here so I mean these
look beautiful there are presumably a
million different parameters for how
long the arrows are and all kinds of
things like that right and how long the
arrows are you know it's gonna be
subject to improvement at some point in
the future hopefully not too far in the
future right so the other thing that the
Geo vector plots Doc's have at the
moment is there was a meeting I don't
know six months or so ago or something
where you suggested that the
visualization functions should document
all of the options yes I think they
should be broken up they are okay
so right now I've been split by things
that are you know particularly
interesting to this function versus
everything else I mean possibly
I think the everything else should be
split up a bit I think that's a bit long
there right I mean this is a mr. project
to do this because there's a lot of
visualization functions correct and I'll
probably not you know I wouldn't do it
here for right now I would just
grandfather these as we've done for
other things right now okay we'll pick
this up in twelve one sounds good
um okay anything else we need to go with
this I don't think so I think so there's
also Geo stream plot which is you know
this stream plot is two most vector plot
is the Geo things are but what is not
obvious I mean a stream plot really is
taking of is it also taking vectors
formulas it takes the same input as geo
vector plot no I understand that but is
it obvious a stream plot and principle
is taking infinitesimal or am i confused
here in other words the vector actually
has a destination point there might be
twenty miles away or something or is
that really it really gets you a vector
field you can interpolate it and you can
solve along it instead of straight like
a tangent I mean what one is like the
tangent space and the other is some kind
of finite difference he thing well I
mean you could also view it this yeah
it's a differential equation system of
differential equations and those are
some reference along it fair enough fair
enough
what is that is that real but weird
picture of it so it's updated a little
bit since that was a you know but it is
ok as we going an actual set of vectors
ok I need but ok syrota so yeah I mean
if you evaluate it that you know copy
didn't evaluated it you would see the
new appearance of it which do we still
have Jeremy
yeah here okay okay it's a blue spider
instead of a black spider like this
inside a frame a little bit smaller yeah
it looks nice but I mean it looks
perfectly okay at least
yeah is that they are the two vectors
it's just that they are on the same
point yeah I understand
that's fine I mean I think that's some
it serves as a little histogram of yeah
of it's like one of those radar plot
things or something I made
okay looks good and nothing else we need
to go over and that that I can think of
okay
a lot of very nice stuff um okay thanks
to folks on the live stream good
comments and see you soon okay see you
then